i
[Música]
muy buenos días américa latina'
bienvenidos estas son las noticias más
destacadas hasta esta hora de la mañana
aquí en france 24
las fuerzas de seguridad de burkina faso
en áfrica occidental han confirmado la
muerte de al menos un centenar de
personas en un ataque en el norte del
país según el reporte oficial estos
hechos ocurrieron en la localidad de
solán en donde hombres armados
dispararon contra la población y también
incendiaron varias viviendas se
desconoce que el grupo podría haber
perpetrado este ataque que ya es
considerado por las autoridades de ese
país como el más sangriento desde el año
en otros temas en el marco de la reunión
del g7 las economías más desarrolladas
del mundo que tiene lugar en londres en
reino unidos los participantes
alcanzaron un acuerdo histórico
estas siete economías más destacadas del
planeta se comprometieron a realizar una
reforma del sistema fiscal global que
contempla que los grandes consorcios
tecnológicos multinacionales hagan su
contribución en impuestos alrededor del
15% la reforma fiscal entonces cobijaría
a gigantes como google facebook amazon
entre otras empresas que tienen sus
sedes en paraísos fiscales precisamente
para evitar pagar impuestos el anuncio
lo dio a conocer el ministro británico
de economía rising sun'
y vamos hasta colombia este país
atraviesa el momento más dramático en un
largo tercer pico de contagio de kobe 19
que comenzó al término de la semana
santa el país superó la jornada del
viernes la barrera de los 30.000 casos
positivos de contagio y también registró
537 fallecidos 8 - que el día anterior
el repunte de contagio y de muertes
también coincide con el estallido social
que comenzó el 28 de abril y que se ha
prolongado con protestas y con
concentraciones donde no se guarda el
distanciamiento y donde también han sido
vistas algunas personas sin tapabocas a
este panorama hay que añadir el anuncio
hecho por los gobiernos de ciudades como
bogotá y medellín en donde ya las
unidades de cuidado intensivo están
colapsadas allí anunciaron que van a
realizar una apertura comercial y social
completa a partir del 8 de junio
y hablamos ahora de la india este país
registró este sábado el menor número de
contagios con de kobe 19 en los últimos
58 días las autoridades contabilizaron
120 mil 529 casos positivos una cifra
que se aleja del pico de la segunda ola
que semanas atrás dejaba un promedio de
400.000 casos nuevos diariamente y que
puso en alerta a las autoridades también
provocó allí el colapso del sistema
hospitalario el drástico descenso del
número de contagios no se ve reflejado
así en el número de fallecidos que ya
alcanzaron los 3 mil 380 muertes en las
últimas 24 horas contra 4.500 que se
estaban registrando para finales del mes
de mayo
hablamos ahora de perú este país el
viernes entró en la jornada de reflexión
previo a la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales que están
previstas para el domingo después de
cerrar sus campañas el jueves con
multitudinarios actos en lima la capital
por parte de los candidatos keiko
fujimori y pedro castillo el turno llegó
para el presidente saliente francisco
sagasti quien envió un mensaje
televisado a la nación para pedir que
después de los comicios sea acatada la
voluntad del voto popular el mandatario
dirigió estas palabras a los peruanos
dado que en los últimos registros de las
encuestas y también de la intención del
voto
fujimori y castillo tienen un 'empate
técnico' que poco ha fluctuado en las
últimas semanas de campaña
no muy lejos de allí chile es el único
país del mundo en donde el agua está
completamente privatizada revertir esta
normativa es una de las prioridades de
la nueva constitución que cuenta con una
de las mayores reservas de agua dulce
del mundo con este reportaje los dejamos
aquí en france24 siga con nosotros muy
buenos días